all right thank you so this this talk is
going to survey a couple of recent
papers a lot of the joint work with shu
qi chala and ethnic Abeloth and also
with my PhD students down tiger just to
as a public service announcement so
we're diverging in our day of mechanism
design from mechanisms where we're going
to run one mechanism that's worth
billions of dollars to situations that
we're going to run billions of
mechanisms work a dollar okay so that
that change is going to bring in very
different kinds of techniques and
methods for thinking about mechanisms
which are going to be there for very
different okay so I want to introduce
you to the protagonist of this talk and
that is a first price position auction
so many of you are probably familiar
with this concept you have n positions
these positions are ordered in
decreasing wait so the person is the
best the last session is the worst and
you can think of the positions
cohabiting corresponding allocation
probabilities so a bitter assigned to
position i gets allocated with
probability WI okay I'll have n bitters
that values are drawn I ID from a
continuous distribution F and I'm going
to be studying what happens when bids
are in Bay's Nash equilibrium that will
typically look at position auctions
where bidders are assigned positions by
order of bids so all i care about is the
order of bids inefficient auction i
don't care about actual magnitudes of
bids okay bidders will pay their bid
when they're allocated so bitter
allocated mission I is going to get a
receive service would probably wi and
they're going to pay their bid with also
with probably WI okay so here's how I
like to draw a picture of this i have my
positions and I have these double use
them this is the picture I tend to like
to draw in my head so there it is
too many w2's
so the results that I'm going to talk to
you about today are the following coming
from the three papers I had in the on
the cover slide in the exact same order
so I'm going to talk about a result
showing you that the equilibrium in this
iid position auction is efficient
symmetric and unique there's only one
equilibrium in this auction ok I'm going
to talk about how you can do statistical
inference in this option which may be
useful if you want to optimize over all
feasible allocations you can allocate
given some constraints of the ways that
you have to say off from I say revenue
you can do that we're going to actually
be looking at optimizing welfare you'll
see why we need to know the statistics
are as we get into the talk so fiscal
imprint is actually easy in for these
kinds of auctions and then the last
result that I'm going to talk about is
that let's suppose you didn't have an
environment that was a position auction
but you had any old single dimensional
environment with linear utilities and
independent values which is sort of the
canonical model of auction theory if you
have any of these environments I can
reduce that environment to ID petition
auctions and so in some sense if you
understand I deficient auctions you can
understand everything with these caveats
ok so with that said you know this model
of auction theory this auction in
particular is a fundamental auction that
we we understand that we understand very
what we should understand very well and
we actually do it so I'm going to go
over that in the talk ok good so I'm
going to start out with some motivation
for why I care about in particular the
first price variant of position auctions
and the first price target of any
auction and that is the following so
auction theorists like to start doing
auction theory with the revelation
principle which says that if you have an
auction with a good equilibrium there's
always an auction that truthful auction
that has the same quality equilibrium
and so you might as well if you're doing
auction theory first restrict attention
from all possible auctions to only the
ones with truth-telling as equilibrium
and then study those instead okay so
that's the revelation principle there
are some issues with this we actually
saw some in the last section where the
revelation persol didn't apply and
there's some more so if you look in real
life at these mechanisms and again I'm
talking about the kinds of mechanisms
where I have billions of them each worth
a dollar those mechanisms are rarely
truthful mechanisms okay so the fact
that we first restricted the revelation
princeville means we're actually missing
the mechanism we actually care about
okay but good the revelation principal
says if I find a truthful one there
should be the one I actually want in
that class too hopefully and actually
undoing the revelation principle going
to say the first price implementation of
whatever mechanism i want tends to give
you ridiculous see me mechanisms will do
this exercise in the next slide okay so
a conclusion from this high-level
discussion is that we maybe need a
theory for understanding and designing
non revelation mechanisms themselves
from the beginning okay and so I'm going
to be talking about those kinds of ideas
today okay so here's the the motivating
problem I want you to have in your head
throughout the entirety this talk okay
so suppose I really want to solve this
problem I don't want to solve the ID
petition doctrine problem I want to
solve single-minded combinatorial
auctions in a bajan environment okay so
i have m items and bitters bitter i has
value VI for a known bundle SI of goods
and no value for anything else this is
the standard single minded comet or
auction model but i'm going to study in
a beige in setting so players value VI
is drawn independently from distribution
fi and this can be different across the
different players so it's not iid like
the fish and lock and was in the
previous slide okay so i would like to
have a comet oriole auction with first
price payments
and a good base Nash equilibrium that's
my goal okay why do I want this well
maybe because of some rules or something
i'm required to having a first price
auction or maybe because of some other
interactions the second price auction
isn't truthful the VCG auctions not
truthful anyway so I don't care about it
and so this first price auction has
maybe better strategic properties so
let's talk about that before I do I'm
just going to use notation capital X the
same way it was using previous talks for
the set of feasible outcome so Paul Ilya
and everyone was talking about this so
this is just a indicator back here
telling me who served who's not served
and so if two players are served it
better be their sets of items that they
wanted don't intersect ok you can think
single money comment or law students
throughout the talk i'll be talking in
general about any old ex you want yeah
now they're public
okay so the first thing I promised you I
would do is I talked about undoing the
revelation principle so if I want to
design this auction I start out in my
theory land taking the revelation
principle designing the truthful auction
that's bc g ok now i want to undo that
and the way you undo that is to use
revenue equivalents or the payment
identity we'll talk about that more
later but the this is this is how it
goes okay so let's just look at if we
were in vc g what a player would pay an
expectation conditioned on them winning
ok and so for player I with any value VI
they might have I can write the function
SI at VI is the expected payment they
make condition on winning with value VI
okay now what am I gonna do my auction I
get some bids I'm going to then sort of
guess that these these these s eyes were
strategies and invert the strategy from
bids to get values okay well now that i
have values i can use the VCG outcome by
just finding the feasible set that
maximizes the total surplus of values
okay and so then I output that and I'm
going to charge winners their bids and
here's the sort of obvious when you
think about it well if i run this
mechanism what is the bays nash
equilibrium well what is a Bayes Nash
equilibrium one of them is to use the
player to use strategy profile s okay
and that's because it's the strategy
profile that gets them exactly their VCG
equivalent payoff and it has exactly the
same allocation rule as vcg and it has
the same effect the payments is BCG and
therefore the base a decoration tell you
that's in equilibrium okay so um is this
a good mechanism do we like this
mechanism so this is really complicated
because these tragedy functions like you
should you know and your emeka thoughts
and no veas and then the bidders have to
believe that you correctly calculate
these friend it's just ridiculous right
so it's complex how you depending on the
prior you need the prior to calculate
these sis then you need to invert them
so you better need your inversion to not
have like you know large jumps and stuff
because things are not changing very
much and it's a huge project there could
be more equilibria if you did this
noisily with algorithms that weren't
quite right as Paul and others were
saying this is just going to be a mess
okay here's another approach this
approach is to follow the perspective of
the price of Anarchy literature that is
let's look at simple mechanisms that are
in this space that I'm going to plug
with my battery
look at simple mechanisms in this space
and prove that these simple natural
mechanisms have good equilibria this is
not really mechanism design its
mechanism analysis and you have to get
lucky that you identify some simple
things that happen to have good
equilibria in the first place
okay so here is the simplest possible
thing you might think of for a
single-minded comment or auction I'm
going to ask for bids I'm going to
output the set of things that maximizes
the weighted sum of bit of the weighted
allocation by bid right so maximize has
somewhat busy players you serve okay in
charge the winners their bids its first
price okay and fortunately the price of
Anarchy here is n meaning there are
example comet Oriole auctions and
distributions where there are equilibria
based Nash equilibria where the welfare
and equilibria is a factor of n from the
welfare of the optimal outcome okay so
here's another mechanism you could run
and that is well instead of using the
optimal algorithm to optimize your some
abids use a greedy algorithm it turns
out greedy albums have much better
strategic properties and so this
equilibrium going to be much better and
you can show that the equilibrium
actually improves to root em rather than
and actually I probably should have said
mm inner or m is the number of items so
goes from M to root am which is much
better okay but look a root em
approximation actually is still really
terrible okay so we still don't have
simple mechanisms for the setting that
are actually any good okay so here is
again our protagonist the first price
position auction unlike the setting of
single-minded comet or auctions with
asymmetric players the equilibrium is
always efficient symmetric and unique so
it's always optimal so this is a great
situation the actually finding
equilibria it's also really easy in this
auction and so what I'm going to be
showing you in this talk is that this
auction has great properties and
furthermore i can use this auction to
solve my previous single minded
combinatorial option problem and get a
arbitrary close to optimal solution okay
so it's going to be an approximate
reduction i'm going to give you but it's
going to be like a PTAs it's going to
give you for any epsilon you want it'll
give you a 1 minus epsilon approximation
okay I'm actually do this backwards
because i think the real motivation for
me telling all this stuff is this
reduction the fact that these position
auction is just fundamentally important
so after I'd show you this reduction I'm
then going to show you all this nice
properties which hopefully you're then
more much more motivated to see ok so
the reduction ok so here's the
environment i'm talking about i have n
agents they have independent values not
identically drawn just in a pendant
there's some feasibility constraint X
you're trying to optimize social surplus
a actually all the methods are going to
talk about today also apply to revenue
but I'm just going to focus on social
surplus because it's easier so here's
the approach of the reduction ok so
let's consider each bitter and in the
auction they're going to a bid some bi
okay which means given that their value
comes from the distribution there was
some function strategy function mapping
their values two bids and so there's
actually some distribution of bids that
are coming from that bitter the other
bidders face ok let's suppose that i had
t minus one other samples from this
bitters bid distribution ok let's
suppose I had those ok then I could take
this bid and calculate this bidders rank
amongst those other bids from the same
distribution meaning where is this
bitter in the order of all these bids ok
and then I'm going to given all the
ranks of all the bidders who actually
show up okay neither ranks of bidders
amongst their own distribution not ranks
of these bidders amongst I don't care
about this is for bitter i only i do
this now i have bitter eyes ranks at
fuzzy's fifth ok and suppose bitter j a
second ok so given all these rank
information I then allocate to the N
bitters optimally given the rank
information only
she's our question yeah the ranks you
throw the G distributions away are you
taking account of the g's when you're up
too late no everything's starting light
only the ranks to break information
homie well we'll get there okay so let's
suppose I only tell you the ranks of
some bitters but you know their values
are drawn from the distribution f fi for
each bitter okay so given I had tea
samples from a bid distribution I told
you this bitter is fifth you could
update your prior on their value to get
a posterior distribution on what their
value is given that their fifth okay and
given your update actually since you
only use the ranks all you care about is
the expected order statistic of this
bitter so these fifth you care about the
fifth order statistic of your
distribution okay so what do you do
given only the rank information you can
you calculate the expected order
statistic of that bitter and you then
optimally allocate given the order
sistex given the expected order
statistics so given the values they have
an expectation from your posterior you
allocate
ok so to do this we need to know GI
which is no you're this you know fi I
don't caliber out the order cystica bids
I kept your sis couple use I want to
optimize value a bitter even cope with
the ring did you step to wheel me these
are five but I'm about to fill in this
blank space here is he always space I
have to fill in okay good so we're in
the environment where we're running
millions of billions of mechanisms that
are worth a dollar which means where did
I have these distributions and stuff
well probably i ran the mechanism before
ok so imagine for player i it's actually
a population of players and i actually
read like them before on this this kind
of player and before I have the random
draws so I'm just going to say let's
just use t minus one previous runs of
the mechanism to get these values ok so
now I don't need to know gee I just look
back at my data okay for the last t
minus one times I ran this and use those
bids and so each player I say well how
did you compare verse the last team
minus one bids I have people in your
role in the mechanism
sorry when you say expected order
statistics how would you how would that
about not sure I understand the
parenthetical remark okay so an order
statistic is a random variable and its
expectation is the expected one alright
so the fifth or stick it's a random
variable or I just care about a
suspected value because I am dating end
of the day get the expected value if i
allocate to that guy so I don't care
where its exact value is I need to know
some information about the distribution
so this is not so when I before I put up
this single-minded comment or auction it
inverted this strategy function right so
we had that's information to I play math
have a lot less information to do this
will actually make that really formal
what information we need yeah when two
mechanisms and the participants are all
different over time so the participants
today all different from yourself I'm
gonna make the story very concrete in
the next slide okay so but yes what you
think is going to happen is going to
happen yeah can you say something about
why this assumption is importantly
different from just knowing gene for
doing this billions of times so why not
just say you know gee if you're willing
to say you can line up these previous
bids as being from the same type of
better that's fine um however I think
working with an empirical distribution
is better than working with an exact
distribution because then I'm worried
about how correctly I've estimated this
and all I'm saying is actually just use
the t minus 1 samples that you have okay
so yeah you could i mean i'm using a
weaker assumption and it's sufficient
okay so what does player I think about
this mechanism well they're going to get
one of these ranks because they're
basically competing with other the t
minus one other copies of themselves to
get ranked right and so what is my
mechanism due to a player ranked five
player I at their rank five it allocates
them with some probability independently
of their bid okay so if you're ranked
five you get some allocation probability
for player I think of it never being the
same guy different people in the same
role you don't know what the previous
people did I that's right the players on
observe history there's new players
drawn from the distribution each time
okay so I want to I want to state this
again so from player eyes perspective
the outcome of this mechanism looks to
them like 80 player position auction
because I didn't use their bid
information i'll use their rank
information so they're basically
competing amongst the t minus one other
bidders that came previously to be high
ranked okay and once I know your rank
this step two is going to induce a
probability of service for every rank
you could have okay those are your
position weights okay so it looks to a
player like a position auction okay you
can ask how good is this additional
option compared to the optimal welfare
and as you let T grow large you would
assume that you get arbitrarily close to
the oplan welfare indeed you do and that
rate that we were we proved in this
paper is something like root and over T
so sorry maybe I don't remember all the
beginning but this last CRM about the
high welfare what do you say so long
time distributions these values is
independent what is the single
dimensional or fires are single
dimensional yes maybe just how much you
allocate to them that's all there's no
okay this is the standard single
dimensional linear utility model of
auction theory so these are results for
any setting in that single dimensional
linear model of auction theory okay good
so I want to answer some of these
questions I've had about exactly what is
the model which I'm using for previous
rounds so here this is supposed to be
informal so suppose I had these samples
for example here right now let's try to
make that more formal okay so we're
talking about the independent private
value model I have n bitters bitter eyes
values VI drawn from publix tribution fi
I want to start by asking the question
when does this model make sense okay
does this model make sense if we're
going to run an auction once to sell
billions of dollars of spectrum no okay
and that model we're going to have to we
probably are not going to be imagining
people are responding two priors that
are come like this okay this model makes
sense in mechanism settings settings of
mechanism design wears a lot of
uncertainty in what's going on love and
certainty and who you're going to be
competing with which you bless why you
model uncertainty here and you're we're
able to learn about this uncertainty you
have maybe by repeated interactions in
the game or something so something's
happening a lot okay so I'm going to
take the following a population
interpretation of the independent
private value model which is which is
this so let's imagine I have for each
bitter in the stage game of the
mechanism a population so all that end
population is total
in each population bidders have
deterministic values fixed values okay
then what do i do when i run my
mechanism I independently draw a bitter
from each population and run the
mechanism in that population ok the
thing I really care about is and we're
doing a lot of this so we're going to
actually repeat this independently maybe
indefinitely okay and I'd like to have
good mechanisms for this iterative
population model okay so I think I've
answered probably the questions about
exactly what my model is this is my
model good so in this iterative
population model with some feasibility
constraint X what am I going to do now
making my mechanism more specific from
the previous slide i'm going to call
this the ranking order statistic
mechanism so given my bids in each
iteration i'm going to calculate the
rank of bid I from t minus 1 previous
calls to the mechanism of this bitter
which is independent draws from the same
population okay and then I'm going to
allocate the surplus to optimize the
following thing the surplus of expected
order statistics of the values given the
ranks Oh case of each rank of a player I
know what the expected order statistic
is of people from that population with
that rank for key drawers and I use
those fixed numbers in my mechanism to
optimize in step 2 as been pointed out I
am NOT studying a dynamic situation in
terms of bidding behavior
I'm assuming that bidders been in
equilibrium for what's happening which
is this okay so each and in fact to look
at what's happening if I figure out what
each bidder thinks so they get to play
once they never play again basically
imagine my population to continue them
okay and they you know to each to them
it looks like they're drawn from a ID
distribution and they're competing for
these ranks so let's sit down like a
position to auction so that's the
equilibrium is going to happen is the
equilibrium of a position auction okay
oh I have that here so again these
players league player I is competing
with these t minus one other players to
be the one who's ranked each rank right
and so they compete in this position
auction because each rank corresponds to
an allocation probability in this
downstream mechanism okay and as I said
before it's this approximation ya know
in which area they are and they play
Beijing mess with the realm given that
doesn't matter which period that they're
in the periods are all symmetric that is
a startling no you're running forever
if you wish you could imagine a ongoing
mechanism that's where the where the
fundamentals are very very slowly
evolving much slower than T okay so T
for instance like how slowly things of
all in your population puts a ballot how
big t candy if you want you're gonna
give it that way you two look like
expect naively that the rate would be
square root instead of cube root is
there a good reason yeah so let me um
discuss the the proof a second so if you
restrict to values that are bounded
between zero and one okay then you could
analyze the additive loss of this
mechanism and in fact at a prior paper
with Bobby and AH siraj that you could
interpret a theorem of that paper is
actually proving this bound with a
square root okay now the reason why we
lose the square root and get the the
cubic root is to deal with the obstacles
and going from a bounded range to the
fact that there could be very rare
people that very high value okay now the
bad thing about rare people very high
value is when you look at their order
statistics they might not show up they
might not like influence the orcs let's
get very much but when they do show up
you really want to serve them and you
might not be because they expected worse
to tick is low okay so how do you
address this well people show up very
rarely but a very high value fortunately
show up very rarely so in fact they
never show up together and no one
notices they show up so you can
basically do whatever you want for these
guys ok and so balancing these terms of
never showing up and doing whatever you
want is going to introduce the cubic
term
any more questions on this I'm still
confused so it seemed back in each round
we're actually running a different
mechanism because you're what you're
because the map of your rank to the to
the steps to the order statistics is
different according to the rounds but
somehow you're assuming they're playing
in the same equilibrium GI doctor so
your first assumption was wrong so in
each runner running the exact same
mechanism but actually another way to
think about this that might help you is
imagine instead of for each player
looking back t minus I rounds instead
what's batching groups of tea so let's
take T rounds of this magazine call it
one mechanism instead of looking back i
also look like for each player i look
basically over that interval of window t
okay and then you exactly at this dish
and auction interpretation and then
observe the following for each player I
there's no difference in looking back t
minus K and Ford k and just looking back
t minus 1 in terms of what you do it's
an equivalent probabilistic question to
them yeah a game not just a game that
the players for small things to do it's
a game in which you playing with all the
first players and future players as well
right because your depends on that so is
the cerium says peregian spatial nash
equilibrium of this big game that has
this infinitely many players this you
get this approximation so the there
let's talk about uniqueness of
equilibrium in first place efficient
auctions the theorem is that for each
agent I this looks like a position
auction okay you are not actually
competing it's like the problem they are
solving is equivalent to efficient
auction okay there's a stationary
distribution two bids that you get in
these auctions and your special
supplying those bids there's only one
equilibrium there so there's only one
thing that happens and actually I would
love to now talk about that
okay so how do you prove uniqueness of
equilibrium in an auction you show that
there exists an equilibrium that you
likes of the welfare optimal equilibrium
exists I'm going to skip that that's
standard the then you show that among
all symmetric equilibrium there's only
one and that's also standard both of
these use the revenue equivalence
theorem and then to show non-existence
of asymmetric equilibrium you could use
a bunch of differential equations what
I'm going to do is show you the revenue
equivalence proof of this result that
there are no asymmetric you librium
using only read an equivalence to do
that to tell you revenue equivalents
which is starting from the standard base
national edition of Myerson the
allocation rule from a player is a
function of their value in equilibrium
is X I and it's a function increases in
their value and the payment they get is
given by this formula let's understand
the formula so here's X I month on
increasing this term VIX I just gives
you a square of width the eye height x I
this integral is the area underneath the
curve that's that okay and so the
payment has to be the area above the
curve good for you guys for this talk
all i care about is this if you tell me
the allocation the utilities the area
underneath the curve
great this is known as revenue
equivalents in fact the payment identity
and radicals are basically the same
thing that auctions were the same
allocation will have the same revenue so
now I want to show non-existence of a
cmf equilibrium I'm going to restrict to
just a single item option here the proof
extension to position options is is
almost no extra work and this will
simplify the notation so we'll do that
here's a first theorem you might want to
show suppose they have two players in a
first price auction with a random
reserve that we don't know in advance
but we do know the distribution of it
then this two player option has no
asymmetric equilibrium okay that is
going to apply a corollary that an end
player first price options there no
asymmetric equilibrium why is that well
player one and two faced a random
reserve given by the distribution of
bids of players three through n so if
players wanted to have to have the same
symmetric Librium here by the theorem ok
but then repeat the same argument for
players one and I so everyone's playing
the same strategies ok so it suffice is
to prove this theorem this is the thing
I'm going to prove on the next slide
using revenue equivalents
okay so how do all revenue equivalence
proofs work they work by using two
equations for the fundamentals on the
fundamentals of the problem i'm going to
use utility so two equations for the
agents utility we have equation 2 which
comes from the revenue equivalence
formula this came from the previous
slide careful Nash equilibrium it's the
integral of the area underneath the
allocation rule but if it's a first
price option I have another equation for
a player's utility coming directly from
the definition of the auction rules so
if they have value V and may bid sfv and
may win with probability X of e their
utility is there value minus their bid x
it probably they win that's from a first
price definition okay now i have two
equations for utility i'm going to use
those to get a contradiction in multiple
equilibrium ok so my proof is by
contradiction and I'm going to assume
the strategies crossed twice if they
cross 0 times or one time a variation of
the exact same proof can argue that
can't happen either ok so we're just
going to see one of the parts of the
proof which is when they cross twice ok
so here's my picture I have value space
here and I've drawn the bids that
Pitters are making is a function of
their stress and here's bitter one
beating out bit or two over some
interval where they cross twice I'm
trying to prove that can never happen
okay a claim i'm going to use as a sub
claim here which i'm not going to
actually show but it's kind of obvious
is if at the same value player one is
bidding higher than player two then
player 1 it's also winning with higher
probability then player 2 in that
equilibrium it's kind of obvious you
have to write it down and be careful but
and i'm not going to do it let's just
assume it okay so I have these
strategies across this point where
player to one is outfitting player too
so we conclude that the allocation rule
of player 1 is strictly bigger the
allocation will play or two on this
entire interval okay now by equation to
one of my equations for utility i can
write down the difference in utility of
player 1 for values on this interval so
the difference in utility from v prime
to be double prime v prime is this area
underneath the curve here okay by the
fact that x1 is strictly bigger the next
to on this interval that is strictly
bigger than the difference in player 2's
utility
okay but now let's use claim one and
equation 1 our second equation so claim
one says this inequality holds but it's
equal if they're equal okay and so at
the end points B prime u double prime
they're exactly crossing and so they're
their allocations are equal so if their
bids are equal and their allocations are
equal then by equation 1 they have to
have the exact same utility which means
their difference in utilities must be
the same contradiction
yeah there's some continuity of
strategies being in fact I did assume
that I didn't say it out loud is on my
previous slide for this talk i assume
continuous strategies in the paper we do
discontinuous ones this is the main idea
though and that you can see much more
cleanly with a continuous strategies
what did you use the unknown that was on
the previous where'd I use it and I
claim one has to argue that something
with this reserve I don't need to use
the reserve I just need to make sure its
robust to that and claim one deals with
that okay inference what is the foot of
the setting in which you can show you
Nicholas um this is ranked based rules
with payments based on your bid not
other things that are happening okay so
GSP the second price payment rule which
where your payment basically based on
other people's bids doesn't hold unique
it doesn't hold and we know you can send
home for a second price rules so in the
actual option so though some deductions
of the position auction sale look at
about getting a higher position but how
might you care about that depends on the
strategist of the other bidders that are
playing with you right okay but I rank
will give you make me more likely to win
but it also you know so I want you to
remember that once i compute these
expected values every the other suppose
your player one there's some other
player too okay so player 2 is uniform
from all of their ranks always and so
no player two is always uniform amongst
their bids and therefore is uniform
amongst the ranks squ those using
yesterday yes no these are different
bidders what I'm thinking about what
about the equilibria where players use
different strategies I'm different so
let's talk offline because I want to
talk about inference so there is no
problem with that let's talk offline
okay let's talk about inference so I
want to talk about a very specific three
bitter example setting to talk about
inference so auction a is selling one
item to one of three bidders auction be
is selling two items to three bidders
and I'm going to consider oxygen see
which is mixing between a and B which is
going to sell one item and half an item
and this looks like a position auction
ok the question I want to ask is if
those I've observed bids and see can you
estimate the revenues of a and B so if i
run one auction can you estimate the
revenues of another auction and it turns
out if these auctions are all position
auctions this is a really simple task ok
just to give you an overview of the
results we're going to talk about if you
have n bit samples from bid see you're
doing an end position auction and your
auction be you ran with probability
epsilon ok then I can estimate the bids
of the revenue of a and B directly from
bids and see directly I never infer
values so directly inferring revenue ok
my estimator is very simple it's a
weighted order cystic what does that
mean I have some weights I've computed
beforehand I take my bids I sort them I
take the weights and I multiply them
point wise and sum them up and that's my
estimator ok no complicated bandwidth
functions or anything that you usually
do if you're doing this kind of
inference my timer says for
so the Rev investor is a weight or I
mean I can stop at one if you want I'm
just saying my timer says for your going
stuff in one so this estimator for
revenue be has error that's this is the
the bound we were able to prove for it's
the standard square root the number of
samples you'd expect and then you have
some terms based on the number of
players incision auction and most
significantly the dependence on epsilon
the probability that you actually ran be
is logarithmic in one over epsilon and
this should seem quite surprising
because if you actually did an ideal
controlled experiment where you said
epsilon traffic to a and got the bids an
a and 1 minus epsilon traffic to be and
got the bids in B and they just added
those revenues up then you'd have error
basically square root of 1 over epsilon
right because your number of samples you
have is is epsilon m so the error would
be square root of epsilon m okay so we
get this bound let's see i have one
minute to tell you how this works
so this is the standard way you do a
Cano metric inference so you you
basically solve for the bitters values
in terms of their biz and you get this
is the equation to convert bids into
values and the big annoying thing here
is you need an estimate it for the
derivative of bids ok this is bids and
great abids and some allocation rules ok
you then plug in your values and solve
for equilibrium and calculate revenues
this is the equation for revenue an
option given the values ok if you do
this by calculating values you have to
do all this stuff that gets really bad
rates and stuff with bandwidth functions
decimate derivative bids so what we do
is we actually just plug these equations
together before we try to do anything
and then we have an integral with a
derivative which we don't like we
integrate by parts to get rid of it and
we get a term that looks like this some
coefficient times the bid function which
is if you then look at it even intervals
of 1 over n gives you a way to artistic
ok and so that's that ok to conclude I'd
addition auctions they're actually
implicit in every independent private
value model so therefore something
worthy of very careful study and I
showed you they have all these nice
properties and thank
still have one minute
thanks again